dix jours après le drame le président
mobutu ouvre les portes de sa résidence
la villa del mar pour recevoir le maire
de menton l'élu tout comme le quai
d'orsay insistent pour obtenir la levée
de l'immunité diplomatique de l'auteur
de l'accident
une mesure également demandé par
l'ambassadeur lui-même après un quart
d'heure d'entretien dans un salon de la
villa
le conseiller spécial du chef de l'état
transmet les condoléances du président
mobutu aux familles ainsi que sa
position sur la requête de la france il
insistera auprès du gouvernement
vahirua pour diligenter dans le sens
positif au la demande de levée de
l'immunité diplomatique de l'ambassadeur
ramazani et ceci devra suivre la
procédure légale au zaïre c'est à dire
la position du gouvernement pression de
la rue pression des élus pression du
ministère des affaires étrangères
la crise est peu à peu désamorcé après
l'entretien de la ville à la procédure
légale est dans les mains du
gouvernement a droit pour la famille le
noir qui a perdu son fils de 13 ans
c'est un premier pas vers la justice
j'attends donc effectivement très
rapidement que le parlement allait roy
confirmé en terrine
disons la décision et disons-le avis
favorable du président mobutu dont je
note également que monsieur
l'ambassadeur est prêt à se livrer à
justice française on se dirait ça ne
peut que l'honorer à travers le drame
qu'il a créé lundi prochain le président
mobutu invitera à nouveau le maire de
menton pour le tenir au courant de
l'évolution de cette procédure
diplomatique
une situation qui pourrait faire
jurisprudence dans les conventions
internationales